beneath the waves off the coast of West
Wales what could turn out to be one of
the UK's most important crops and
volunteers are here to harvest it
seagrass is what they've come for or at
least its seeds the water in many places
is not as clear as it is here poor water
quality has wiped out most of the
nation's seagrass meadows which are
vital for many reasons it creates this
huge kind of habitat that's really sort
of complex and complicated for for
biodiversity to live in so you get lots
of animal sorts of fish particularly
species like the Atlantic cod the
herring they use sea grass as a nursery
habitat it was really important for all
those big economically important
fisheries but there's an even more
important reason why seagrass Meadows
should be protected for all of us they
are excellent at extracting harmful
carbon from the atmosphere in fact they
can do this 35 times faster even than
tropical rainforests and scientists
believe that seagrass is key to
providing a solution to climate change
in a project supported by the World
Wildlife Fund Swansea University and Sky
Ocean rescue a million seeds are being
collected
they'll be taken to a lab and the shoots
will be replanted in an underwater site
in South Wales the size of at least two
football pitches wildlife expert dr.
Jenny Oates says politicians globally
should stop overlooking the role that
sea grass can play in reversing climate
change governments haven't been doing
enough just in the UK we've lost over
90% of our seagrass beds but I think
they're starting to realise the
importance of this habitat as a
protection for marine wildlife but also
as a really important way of addressing
the climate emergency so they really
need to wake up to this it's hoped the
operation here will prove that with
political support a mass reintroduction
of seagrass Meadows around the UK
coastline and beyond can repair much of
the damage inflicted on our planet
particularly over the past 100 years
Mike McCarthy Sky News paused in line
North Wales